antes de contarles por qué el precio de
las viviendas subió hasta el cielo creo
que sería muy bueno contarles una breve
historia del mercado inmobiliario y cómo
es que operaban las hipotecas antes de
que todo esto se saliera de control así
que regresamos en el tiempo a la década
del 70
vámonos no sé a mediados de la década de
los 70s y yo recuerdo que en aquellos
tiempos
mis padres compraron una casa y vivíamos
en nueva orleans y la casa sí recuerdo
correctamente costaba alrededor de 60
mil dólares y en esa época para que tú
puedas pagar una casa necesitabas pagar
un enganche y si recuerdo bien el
enganche era como de un 25 por ciento
del valor de la casa es decir de una
cuarta parte del valor total de la casa
que en este caso son 15 mil dólares
porque es un cuarto de 60 mil dólares y
tenías quedar en esa época un enganche
de 15 mil dólares y todo lo demás es
decir 245 mil dólares restantes se iban
a tu hipoteca era tu deuda que tenías
que pagar y bueno vamos a suponer que
tenías una tasa de interés alta una tasa
de interés del 9 por ciento entonces
vamos a calcular la el 9
por ciento de 45.000 es igual a 45.000
dólares por punto 09
me dan 4 mil 50 dólares 4.050 dólares lo
que vas a pagar de puro interés al año
recuerden que es una tasa de interés al
año y si quiero saber cuánto me da esto
entre 12 entre 12 meses vamos a pagar
337 puntos 5 dólares al mes de interés
pero vamos a redondear lo en 340 dólares
al mes esto de puro interés y recuerdo
que en aquella época tuvimos que rentar
esta casa y mudarnos a otra porque no
teníamos dinero no teníamos nada de
dinero y decidimos rentar esta casa y
bueno no olviden que hablo de los años
70 y después de estos tiempos rentamos
esta casa a 900 dólares por mes 900
dólares por mes y bueno es que esta
historia me deja un par de preguntas la
primera gran pregunta que tengo es por
qué la gente va a pagar esta casa por
900 dólares al mes bueno supongo que
tenían los ingresos buenos o que tal vez
no tienen grandes deudas pero lo que fui
es porque pagar estos 900 dólares al mes
cuando
de pagar esta renta podría estar
comprando esta misma casa a un pago más
económico o si te das cuenta la hipoteca
de la casa que tengo aquí es de 400
dólares más o menos al mes mientras que
las rentas de 900 dólares al mes y bueno
este es el clásico argumento de rentar
contra comprar una casa porque rentar la
casa de 900 dólares la puedes comprar
por cerca de 400 dólares estamos
hablando del mismo lugar y la diferencia
es muy grande y bueno el primer problema
que se me ocurre es que para tu compra
esta casa necesitas contar con 15 mil
dólares de ahorros de eso no te salvas y
tal vez estas personas que estaban
rentando la casa de mis papás no tenían
esta cantidad y por lo tanto estaban
rentando la casa de mis papás mi segundo
candidato o mi segunda hipótesis que
tengo es que ellos no tenían un trabajo
estable pero no lo veo muy factible
porque si mis papás hubieran sabido que
estas personas no tenían un trabajo
estable no les habían rentado la casa
ahora bien una tercera hipótesis que se
me ocurre es que ellos no tuvieran un
buen historial crediticio recuerda que
para que te presten el dinero necesitas
tener un buen historial crediticio es
decir que no tengas deudas
lo que hayas pagado a tiempo y todo esto
para que el banco te preste el dinero
así que esa podría ser una tercera
hipótesis tal vez estas personas no
tenían un buen historial crediticio
aunque si me lo preguntan de verdad de
verdad cuál es mi opinión yo creo que no
teníamos 15.000 dólares ahorrados y
estoy casi convencido de ello porque si
no no tendrían por qué estar pagando
esta renta pero bueno en general ese era
el problema cuando querías comprar una
vivienda en esas épocas había una gran
barrera para conseguirla muy a pesar de
la ideología popular que dice que es
mucho mejor comprar una casa que rentar
una casa y esto todo el mundo lo saben
pero pese a ello no todos tienen su casa
porque porque tal vez no tengan el
dinero para dar el enganche una casa o
bueno puede ser que no tengan un trabajo
estable o que no tuvieran un buen
historial crediticio etcétera pero lo
que voy es que esto fue lo que pasó de
1970 a 1980 1990 hasta el año 2000 y
bueno tal vez en california hasta el año
1990 pero vamos a generalizar todo en el
año 2000 y lo que pasó en el año 2000 es
que empezaron a cambiar estas
condiciones empezaron a bajar y tal vez
haga después
otro vídeo para ver qué es lo que estaba
pasando pero por ahorita vamos a notarlo
en la década de los 80 necesitabas un
25% de enganche para comprar tu casa
también necesitabas un empleo estable
también necesitabas no sé vamos a
suponer que unos 700 puntos crediticios
y bueno todo esto pasaba desde la década
del 80 hasta el año 2000 esto para
darles una idea pero ahora que vamos al
año 2001 que pasó aquí lo que pasó en
ese momento es que estas condiciones
empezaron a disminuir es decir que si
querías comprar una casa tal vez
necesitaba solamente ahora el 10% de
enganche de la casa sólo el 10%
estable es más ya ni siquiera un trabajo
estable te pedían tener trabajo y además
le bajaban a 600 puntos crediticios para
darte el préstamo de la casa y bueno la
pregunta que me hago es porque los
bancos cambian sus estándares así pues
vamos a pensar en todas las personas que
estaban rentando una casa por 900
dólares mensuales quedamos que ellos no
tenían 15 mil dólares de enganche eso es
cierto pero vamos a suponer que algunos
ya tenían el 10% ahorrado es decir
tenían 6000 dólares ahorrados y bueno
vamos a suponer que tienen trabajo y
tienen 600 puntos de historial
crediticio llegamos al 2001 recuerda que
en la década del 80 todavía no se puede
hacer esto y ahora si ya pueden ser
candidatos a comprar una casa y entonces
se ponen felices y ambiente en la casa
por la ventana diciendo genial no
tenemos que rentar una casa de nuevo en
nuestras vidas y por lo tanto estos
cambios aumentan la demanda en la oferta
de las casas suponiendo que el salario
no ha subido suponiendo que la población
no ha aumentado la demanda de la casa se
aumentó pues cambiando estas condiciones
más gente puede tener un financiamiento
de esta casa
y ahora si pensamos en el año 2003
seguramente hubo un primer banco que
dijera sabes que es más ni necesitas
pagar nada en un principio ni un solo
dólar así que imagínate la cantidad de
personas que existen que están
interesadas en comprar una casa
seguramente en esa época también te
sigan pidiendo un trabajo o tal vez
solamente te piden los 500 puntos
crediticios y otra vez los salarios no
han aumentado vamos a suponer que la
población no ha aumentado pero la
demanda de casas volvió a aumentar o al
menos hay más gente que aspira a comprar
una casa y entonces esta situación se
puso cada vez más pesada por ahí del año
2004 2005 nos topamos con los casos que
se desconoce como ingresos declarados o
también se les llama préstamos
mentirosos y es que esto significan que
los bancos ya no te piden enganche
inicial ya solamente te piden que tengas
trabajo pero es que fíjate aquí el
problema es que tú puedes llegar y decir
tengo trabajo y te prestan el dinero eso
es lo que se llama un ingreso declarado
pues lo único que te pedían era decir
cuánto ganaba en un cierto mes recuerda
que es importante que tú tengas que
pagar al mes algo de interés
hipoteca todo esto mensualmente por lo
tanto llegaban personas a decir yo gano
diez mil dólares al mes cuando realmente
ganaban dos mil dólares mensuales y con
esto les daban su casa pues ya muchos
bancos ni te pedían historial crediticio
y entonces aquí el problema porque
muchas veces no tenían ese dinero para
pagar la casa para pagar la hipoteca y
entonces les quitaban la casa ahora la
pregunta es qué pasó en el año 2004 2005
pues lo que pasó es que endeudarse se
hizo cada vez más sencillo y eso provocó
que mucha gente se estuviera endeudando
y por lo tanto también cada vez había
más gente que no tuviera dinero pero
entonces llegaban y diciendo bueno voy a
pedir un préstamo al banco y se les
otorgaba entonces aumentó más la demanda
de casas cada vez más grande fue esta
demanda que hasta hizo que las casas
aumentan así sus precios en esos años
ahora la pregunta que yo me hago es por
qué está pasando todo esto fue fácil en
un principio en el año 2001 empezar a
bajar estas condiciones así es cada vez
más fácil y más fácil y más fácil
endeudarse
llegará al 2004 de qué sirve llegar a
este nivel completamente absurdo en la
forma de endeudarte con una casa y es
que en esos tiempos hoy éxito les
impresionantes de personas que decían
que con un ingreso anual de 40 mil
dólares al año ya podían financiar su
casa y esto es justo lo que quiero ver
en la siguiente parte en el siguiente
vídeo analizar en qué y por qué está
afectando todo este comportamiento